ده المطار بشكل الجزئي الى العمل او القسم
المدني للمطار هو الذي عاد الى العمل ولكن
القسم الذي تعرض للقسم الاسرائيلي لا يزال
يحتاج الى اعاده صيانه بالاضافه لاستهداف
مستودع في حرم المطار وايضا مبنى اخر في
محيط المطار المباني التابعه لحزب الله
لبناني وليست لقوات النظام التضرر هو في
القصر الذي يعرف بالقسم العسكري او القسم
السابع للجهات الدبلوماسيه والذي هو لا
تهبط فيه طائرات مدنيه
طائرات شحن حتى اللحظات هذا القسم هو معطل
وعلى ما يدل الرساله الاسرائيليه واضحه
بان مطار دمشق سوف يستهدف طالما ان هناك
طيران ايراني يهبط في هذا المطار وينقل
السلاح عبر مطار دمشق الدولي
وقد افدتم بان العدد وصل الى اربعه اشخاص
بينهم جنديان سوريان هل من معلومات عن حجم
الاضرار الماديه
كبيره في حرم المطار في المبنى الذي
استهدف وفي محيط المطار والمباني هي
معروفه للجميع حتى يعني ابناء تلك المناطق
يعلمون بان هذه المستندات لحزب الله
اللبناني ما بارك اسرائيل هذه المستودعات
دمرت وتدمر وهناك بنك اهداف لاسرائيل
عندما يعلم بوصول السباحه عليها ان
يستهدفها ولكن بالنسبه للخسائر البشريه
هناك اسنان من الجنسيه السوريه واثناء
الجنسيه غير سوريا عاملينه مع الميليشيات
ايرانيه